the best way to experience the speech
API is with a demo before I get into it
I want to explain a bit how it works
so we're going to make a recording I
wrote a bash script we're going to use
socks to do that as a command-line
utility for audio so what we'll do is
we'll record our audio we'll create an
API request in a JSON file we'll send it
to the speech API and then we'll see the
JSON response so if we could go ahead
and switch to the demo okay I'm gonna
make the font a little bigger so I'm
going to call my file with bash request
SH and it says press Enter when you're
ready to record it's going to ask me to
record a five-second audio file so here
we go I built a cloud speech API demo
using socks okay so this is the JSON
request file that it just created we
need to tell the speech API via encoding
type in this case we're using slack
encoding the sample rate in Hertz the
language code is optional if you leave
it out it'll default to English
otherwise you need to tell it what
language your audio is in and then the
speech context I'm going to talk about
that in a little bit so I'm going to
call the speech API it's making a curl
request and let's see how it did okay so
it's it pretty good that I built a cloud
speech API demo using socks but you'll
notice it got the wrong socks because
socks is a proper noun it was 89 percent
confident that it got this correct that
even was able to get API as an acronym
so I mentioned this speech context
parameter before and what this actually
lets you do is let's say you have a
proper noun or a word that you're
expecting your application that's unique
that you wouldn't expect the API to
recognize normally you can actually pass
it as a parameter and it will look out
for that word so I'm going to hop on
over to sublime and I'm going to add
socks as a phrase to look out for and
let's see if it's able to identify it
I'm going to say the same thing again
I'm going to record I built a cloud
speech API demo using socks
and we can see it's now got that phrase
in there and we will call the speech API
and it was able to get it correctly
using the phrases perimeter which is
pretty cool
just one REST API request and we are
easily transcribing an audio file even
with a unique entity and you can also
pass API audio files in over 80
different languages you just need to
tell it again the language code that
you'd like it to transcribe so that is
the speech API